je pense que c'est une question qui va
vous intéresser damien ce que vous avez
déjà simulé au non jamais jamais jamais
jamais j'essaie d'en apprendre plus
évidemment pour un morceau sur l'équipe
et bien tout ce que parce qu'il fait y
figurez vous que ce serait quelque chose
d'assez comminges et ces messieurs voilà
oui c'est nouveau ça vient de sortir
ce n'est pas une exclusivité féminines
c'est ce que nous explique je t'aime et
tu sais ça chez les filles que vous
n'avez pas le monopole effectivement de
la simulation nous aussi nous arrive
d'être absent pendant l'acte de penser à
la liste des courses ou à sa collègue
l'amusé le court 10 ou à autre chose le
cas d'arthur il a accepté de témoigner
au risque de sa vie sentimentale
j'ai déjà simulé pour me donner de
l'enfant pour six minutes tu respires
plus fort tut aguerris peut-être plus et
puis tu fais un peu plus de bruit ça
aide aussi à ceux à se mettre dedans et
je fais finalement pas mal aussi de
s'auto convaincre un peu alors voilà
vous l'avez compris en gros hommes comme
femmes on est capable de mentir chacun
est capable de simuler l'essentiel étant
de trouver le bon partenaire pour
pouvoir aimer sans tricher alors qu'est
ce qu'on en pense messieurs je vous sens
un petit peu gêné qu'est ce qui se passe
à damien maintenant le mois déjà je ne
comprends pas ce concept du hurlement
pendant l'acte sexuel enfin moi j'ai
besoin d'être concentré sur ça me met
pas dire ça c'est pas contrôler
d'histoire à mater les l'acte sexuel a
besoin d'une certaine solennité pour
exécuter le geste parfait si à un moment
donné on vous hurle dans les oreilles
basses à vous saviez vous vous dispersez
vous faites c'est à dire on est ensemble
on sera enfin oui on vit quelque chose
ensemble d'un peu fort bah oui on peut
vivre un truc fort en silence en faisant
mouche sur l'iss jeu sur silence car
vous êtes sûrs aux silencieux et les
comment elle en vibreur elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi je
ne verra pas le centième chroniqueurs et
leur raconter ce qui s'est passé dans
les loges serre que nous les deux
garçons on a très bien compris ce que ça
voulait dire simuler c'est à dire ce que
raconte ce jeune homme à l'antenne je
respire plus forts etc et les filles on
dit quand elle est molle alors c'est
possible oui l'érection c'est pas la
même chose que si ça me regarde pas je
suis pas une experte
non c'est juste que jean-michel on peut
pas comprendre cette news parce qu'une
femme quant à elle un orgasme c'est
perceptible
voilà tu as dit que tu criais fort fort
oui bon ben ça c'est dans cette époque
mais vous quand votre nous il n'est pas
le dente on se rend compte que vous
priez beaucoup la métaphore oui on se
rend compte que bombe a écrit mais il un
peu mou du genou donc on n'y croit pas
c'est mon genou qu'il est mou la
formation l'information première malgré
qu pardonnez moi messieurs c'est que
visiblement nous les femmes on n'a pas
de mal à dire effectivement parce qu'il
ya des nombreux sondages qui le disent
que que les femmes ces mules elles
disent oui moi ça m'arrive une fois sur
4 une fois sur dix une fois je suis pas
sur combien alors que vous messieurs
d'habitude du tout ça que moi en
préparant les missions où ça et je
prépare ce qui se fait dans le bar
caudan l'écran ouais ok petits chiffres
et tout ça et j'ai essayé de trouver des
statistiques sur les hommes qui simule
et moi j'ai pas réussi sa recule mais
s'il n'assume pas du tout ils se disent
oh là faut surtout pas que je dise ça
paye pas un seul une seule étude qui
allait avec une autre et du coup je me
retrouve avec soit 1 69%
j'aime bien ce chiffre soit 1 25% bref
les gars assumer ce pas bien grave ça
nous arrive on le dit toutefois pas moi
on avait la question nos téléspectateurs
à ces messieurs justement et je sais que
tu es spectateurs ne manque jamais tant
aux messieurs est ce que vous simulez
tout le temps vieillit on sent de temps
en temps 30% et jamais c'est vraiment à
3% je voyais là où je vous dis je vous
aime messieurs parce que vous êtes des
menteurs sublime
merci monsieur